SEPTEMBER FOURTH MEETING OF THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
TO HEAR TO HEAR THE- GABRIELLE
GLORIA. GLORIA HERE KILEY KILEY
NEARLY MON. MAIENSCHEIN MENTION
HERE QUIRK SILVA QUIRK SILVA
HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE
ONE ON ONE ITEM ON THE AGENDA
IT'S SB SIX EIGHTY SEVEN MADAM
SENATOR WELCOME. IT SHOULD BE
FAIRLY QUICK. A GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SB SIX EIGHTY SEVEN
WHICH IS A BILL TO INCREASE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS BY ADDING A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM TO THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCIAL COUNCIL CALIFORNIA
HAS MORE HOMELESS PEOPLE THAN
ANY OTHER STATE IN THE NATION
ONE OF THE LARGEST SEGMENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA. OF CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESS POPULATION IS HOMELESS
COLLEGE UNIVERSITY STUDENTS
EIGHT TWENTY NINETY REPORT BY
THE HOPE CENTER FOR COLLEGE
COMMUNITY AND JUSTICE FUND.
FOUND THAT 90% OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS. IN CALIFORNIA
FACE CHALLENGES OF BEING
HOMELESS IN THE PAST SO. WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
ANY WITNESSES. AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WE
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF THE
SENATOR AND STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU
ARE THERE ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS
OF THE BILL. IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND UNLESS THERE'S ANY
DISCUSSION. I JUST WANNA COMMON
I ALWAYS HAVE TO COMMENT ON
THIS ISSUE. THAT TO I THINK
THIS IS VERY MUCH NEEDED IN
NORTH ORANGE COUNTY WHERE WE
DON'T OFTEN. THINK OF
HOMELESSNESS MY TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES FULLERTON COLLEGE AND
CYPRESS COLLEGE NOT ONLY ARE
AWARE OF THE SITUATION BUT
THEY'RE- MAKING STEPS. WHETHER
IT BE FOOD PANTRY WHETHER BE.
AT FULLERTON COLLEGE THEY'VE
ACTUALLY CONNECTED WITH A-
CLOSE BY. RIVER VENDOR THERE
CALLED THE RIVER FARM AND THEY
GROW VEGETABLES AND- AND- SO ON
AND THEY'RE NOW MAKING THAT
CONNECTION SO IT'S NOT JUST.
CANNED GOODS AND SO FORTH BUT I
THINK THAT. THE MORE VOICES WE
HAVE AT THE TABLE THAT
REPRESENT THIS PARTICULAR.
GROUP NOT ONLY IS ESSENTIAL BUT
IT'S. GONNA MAKE A DIFFERENCE
OKAY. GREAT THANK YOU. AND WITH
THAT DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING YOU'D
LIKE TO SANTA CLAUS JUST THINK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION I
ALSO AGREE WITH THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
HAVE LIVED EXPERIENCES AT THE
TABLE TO SHARE. IT WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR APPLE
THANK YOU GREAT AND HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS I THINK WE ALL
KNOW THE CHALLENGES THAT
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE FACING
WITH WORDS HOMELESSNESS SO.
ADDING THE REPRESENTATIVE
YOU'RE PROPOSING MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE WITH THAT LET'S CALL THE
ROLL. OUR MOTION TO PASS A TWO
BY TWO HI DAVE. GABRIELLE
GLORIA GLORIA I KILEY KILEY I
LEE MON. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT QUIRK SILVA
QUIRK SILVA HI EVEN IF TO GET
OUT WILL WAIT FOR ADAM MEMBERS
AND WERE ASK ALL MEMBERS TO
PLEASE JOIN US THANK YOU
. BOB.
RIGHT YEAH THEY'RE ON THEIR WAY
.
YEAH
. YOUR BODY ON THE REMEMBER
THE MONTH THE MONTH I. THANK
YOU. YEAH. THIS GUY HELLO THERE.
I WILL YES. SO MEMBERS HI. YEAH
WE ARE ADJOURNED